euh Gaga est avec nous merci d'être avec
tout le monde
pièges moi si tu peux c'est présenté par
Greg Guillotin que j'aime on va regarder
un teaser et on en parle avec Greg juste
après c'est ce soir sur mycanal juste
après TPMP regarde
bienvenue
chez moi si tu peux vous avez été piégé
c'est pas moi je suis
enferme un de nous
et je sais pas il y a un truc qui pour
vous est un bon menteur autour de cette
table arrêtez de me viser
c'est lui qui m'a donné faux billet
de passer c'était pas moi quoi l'autre
piègeur a tout orchestré qui a les
épaules pour monter tout ça moi j'ai
trouvé
[Applaudissements]
je pense ça va être un énorme carton sur
mycanal je vous le dis tu travailles
dessus depuis combien de temps à moi pas
depuis très longtemps parce que je vais
présenter l'émission monsieur qui ont
préparé ça et dans bossé ça de depuis
pas mal de mois Agatha turbal Loïc alors
raconte-moi on a reçu aussi
personnalités autour d'une table pour un
jeu donc c'est si personne
Mohamed Henni à Marco
qui devait venir aujourd'hui alors il
est où ah ouais je sais pas je
l'embrasse fort je l'adore toi qui vient
ce soir du coup
les
donc les 6 personnes ont été piégées
dans une caméra cachée et le but du jeu
c'est de découvrir qui était le purgeur
parce que le piégeur est autour de la
table voilà et donc ils vont devoir
mener l'enquête voilà puisque c'est ça
qui est d'ailleurs en présentant cette
émission déjà la première mission que je
présentais moi d'accord
c'est gentil c'est gentil et du coup
j'ai plus quoi dire je sais plus ce que
j'allais dire voilà j'étais perdu oui
voilà donc en fait ils sont ils sont
tous pris au jeu c'est à dire que au fur
et à mesure du jeu ils ont commencé à
enquêter il y en a qui prenait des notes
ils regardaient les indices parce qu'il
y a plein d'indices qui sont autour du
plateau et donc en fait c'est un coup de
bluff de et donc ils ont dû découvrir
qui est le purgeur tout le monde
ça a chauffé entre Marco moulin et Momo
et ni regardez
sur la vie de ma mère vraiment
tout de suite
alors là écoute moi je parie 2000 depuis
que tu as dit ça sur la vie de ma mère
4000 non c'est pas vrai on est dans les
fesses sportifs les gars ou on est dans
ouais
[Musique]
et un des pièges un des pièges a été
tourné dans l'émission radio de
Guillaume Genton sur Virgin Radio elle
matin donc 6h 9h30 et avec la chanteuse
neige
dans le mordic sans filtre bravo
bienvenue là le morceau que vous venez
de passer c'était pas moi
pourquoi
[Musique]
mais pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
on fait la promenade
[Musique]
parce que c'est pas nous
qui fait ça
c'est ce soir sur sur mycanal et c'est
un format complètement nouveau c'est
vrai que c'est trop cool parce que on
savait pas comment ça allait se passer
puis au final ils se sont tous investis
dedans et dans c'était trop sympa et en
fait ils ont vraiment mené l'enquête et
puis ils ont on se laisse prendre au jeu
exactement après j'étais en mode
spectateur c'était mais il y avait des
personnalités qui étaient un peu dur
avec analyser là-dedans mais ça va
mais c'est très cool vraiment très fort
et donc voilà bah c'est bon en plus elle
est six pièges ouais il y a les six
pièges et vous allez découvrir vous
pourrez jouer chez vous également à
savoir qui a piéger tous les autres
franchement je pense que ça va terminer
en hiver
en fait c'est un mélange entre le
Laverny mais la taupe d'ailleurs Cyril
la taupe si tu as fait cette émission La
Taupe
comme ça et donc c'est un mélange entre
la taupe le loup-garou et puis la caméra
cachée
je pense que ça va cartonner ça ce sera
ce soir
c'est un format sur mycanal ce soir on
vous propose des choses originales sur
mycanal voilà et donc ça c'est très très
fort et Greg c'est pour Greg qui porte
le format qui animateur du format
vous allez regarder franchement oui
franchement c'est sûr que ce weekend ça
va être un énorme quartier à mon avis à
l'étranger ça ah oui
je veux voir et j'aurais aucun droit
dessus puisque je ne suis que
présentateur voilà
reconnaître le talent c'est une
production française
pourquoi on se prépare on pourrait se
faire un spécial TPMP un jour je te jure
que c'est vrai tu as raison
pour l'instant j'ai que ça ah bah si il
y a un film il faut qu'on s'appelle
on est sur le film
et puis le pire stagiaire qui revient
bientôt exactement sur C8 on vient de
Belgique là on a eu un piège incroyable
ah ouais ouais génial raconte nous un
peu comme ça un agent matrimonial
d'accord ouais et c'était c'était
en relation mais non mais il y a Aurore
on sait quand ça commence on sait jamais
quand ça se termine c'est comme les cars
Jean-Yves merci en tout cas tu restes un
peu avec nous allez allez vas-y ça fait
plaisir d'être à côté de Jean-Michel
toujours ah bah oui c'est un copain bah
ouais depuis longue date ça fait
longtemps qu'on se connaît
tout ça sympa comme mec ah ouais ouais
vraiment